- GOD, THIS PLACE IS SO NICE.
- THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE ONE OF
THE BEST FRENCH PLACES IN TOWN.
- MM, I DID NOT REALIZE
THAT YOU WERE SO CULTURED.
- YOU'RE SWEET.
MY FRENCH IS PRETTY GOOD,
SO I CAN ORDER FOR BOTH OF US.
- OOH.
- IF YOU'D LIKE.
- WELL, WELL, WELL.
- BONJOUR.
WELCOME TO CHEZ
DE LA NOTRE VENDRE,
I AM YOUR WAITER
FOR THIS EVENING.
MY NAME IS
JEAN-LUC DE LA PIERRE-RENAULT,
BUT YOU MAY CALL ME JEAN.
- BONJOUR, JEAN.
- OOH, LOOK AT YOU.
- IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT ANYTHING AT ALL
I AM MORE THAN HAPPY
TO ASSIST YOU--TO ASSIST.
- JEAN?
I GOT IT.
MERCI BEAUCOUP.
- TRES BIEN.
WELL, OUR FIRST SPECIAL TONIGHT
IS OUR POISSON DU JOUR.
IT'S A LOUP DE MER PLUS
[speaking French],
SERVED WITH
A [speaking French],
THAT IS SERVED ON A BED OF
[speaking French]
AND ALSO SERVED WITH
AND [speaking French].
- MMM.
- YUM.
- OUR SOUP TODAY IS
A [speaking French]
WITH A--JUST A DASH OF
[speaking French]
AND SERVED WITH MELTED
[speaking French].
- SOUP.
- YEAH.
- OUR OTHER SEAFOOD TODAY--
WE HAVE A VERY NICE
[speaking French],
FROM THE [speaking French]
VALLEY IN [speaking French].
IT IS SERVED WITH A SIDE OF
[speaking French]
[continues speaking French]
SAUCE.
- MAN, IT'S JUST,
I'M A LITTLE BIT OVERWHELMED.
- HA-HA, YEAH, YES.
OH, GOD,
I'M SO GLAD YOU SAID THAT.
I WAS ABOUT TO SAY
THE SAME THING.
- SO YOU WOULD RECOMMEND GETTING
THE [speaking French]
WITH THE, UM...
OOH, I'M SORRY,
IS THE [speaking French]
IN A HEAVY
[speaking French] SAUCE?
- OH, NO, NO, NO.
IT'S MORE LIKE A
[speaking French] SAUCE.
- WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I'M GONNA DEFER TO HIM
ON THIS ONE,
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THIS STUFF
WAY BETTER THAN I DO.
- OH, YES.
MONSIEUR?
- WHAT?
UM, YEAH.
WE'RE--WE'LL HAVE THE...
SWUND--UH,
THE--
[nasal honking]
I'M--
SHHNN.
[speaking gibberish]
WE'LL TRY THE FLEUR--
IT'S BEEN NICE KNOWING YOU.
HAVE A LOVELY DINNER.